the coachellers proportionately have
loads of benefits they improve blood
flow they can wake you up in the morning
they elevate testosterone encourage
healing but in reality the testosterone
needs to get from going in a cold shower
are not going to turn you to Broly
should you really be in a
fight-or-flight state the mini you ain't
cut many of the proposed the benefits of
cold showers are actually based on the
benefits of cold exposure or plunge
pools or ice baths things that involve
much longer exposures to cold but the
thing that people like the most about
the idea of cold showers is that they
can increase your willpower but to my
mind if you have enough self-discipline
already to have a cold shower every
single morning then you probably have
all the self-discipline you need the
truth of the matter is the
self-discipline even decision making are
actually finite resources so if you use
up all your willpower having a horribly
cold shower then you're actually going
to have less willpower left over for
those useful things then how about you
just go to failure in your workout yeah
cold showers have been useful for you
then that's absolutely fantastic but as
far as I'm concerned cold showers